parce que la grosse lire aussi ensemble
on était à la comédie-française tous les
deux mais toi tu n'étais que
fonctionnaire est maintenant voir
qu'est-ce que tu es maintenant à vous le
jeu 12/12 quoi la société en une sorte
de part entière dis donc tu as parlé du
français oui j'en ai parlé
tu en as dit du bien oui à la bonne
heure non pourquoi je dire une chose
c'est que je suis très très très flatté
que tu m'aies compter ce soir
parmi les étés les joies de ta vie se
met enfin j'ai quand-même pas la
prétention de croire que c'est moi seul
que tu comptes dans ses joies et je
crois que c'est aussi toute la comédie
française
oui oui on dit pas dit pas le contraire
quoi je fais partie du comité maintenant
que j'aurais lâché rien dit j'ai rien
dit non mais trop attention mon cher
payé 50 je suis très influent mais
j'estime imams et aux attentes oui mais
quand même c'est plus moi oui non non
c'est vrai ça a été ça a été vraiment
formidable la comédie française
c'est formidable la preuve c'est qu'elle
en est parti c'est vraiment merveilleux
[Musique]